another news no Russian President
Vladimir Putin is in Istanbul with
Turkey's leader Brett ship type birds
were announced to open a major new gas
pipeline
well the pipeline is known as Turks
stream and it's five years in the making
in order only allows Russia to sell more
gas to Europe it also helps them to
bypass Ukraine well cm Koziol who is
live for us in Istanbul sinem why is the
Turkic Stream pipeline just so important
this has a symbolic importance actually
hell up because the despite bilateral
crisis back in 2015 after turkey shot
down a Russian fighter jet by its
southern border and this project was
halted and back in 2017 two leaders
decided to build this project again and
this is the second direct pipeline
carrying gas from Russia into Turkey and
it is seen as a seal of unbreakable
Turkey and Russia relations and into the
name Turks stream actually it was given
by the Russian President Vladimir Putin
they both leaders are gone and put in
see this project this pipeline as a
connection between the two countries not
only for providing a secure energy
natural gas from Russia to Europe but
also as a secure line of political
relations turkey Russia relations are
not only based on energy supplies or
economic relations as you know two
countries have been allied in the region
when it comes to Syria when it comes to
Iraq and today both leaders actually
touched about these issues for instance
turkish President Recep Tayyip Erdogan
said a turkey doesn't want any tension
any proxy war actually for Libya Lebanon
or Syria this is very important Turkey
and Russia are allies in many many
topics like at the escalation zone and
and all northwestern Syria Italy but
they are fighting that they are actually
keeping the different homes in Libya
Turkey supports the UN recognized
government GNA Russia recognized Arab
supports the Haftar Khalifa Haftar
in Libya but it seems to leaders
discussed Libya the tension in Iraq the
humanitarian condition in Egypt and
Turkey and Russia are also expected to
provide a mediation for Libya as well
okay sinem cthulhu following events
first in Istanbul thank you very much
indeed
well the Turk stream pipeline starts in
the southern Russian town of another and
runs more than 900
hundred kilometers deep on to the Black
Sea to the Turkish town of Akio koi it
can transport over 30 billion cubic
meters of natural gas per year half of
that will be delivered to southern
Europe servicing up to three percent of
the e use current needs Russia already
supplies around 40 percent of Europe's
gas now there it's important because it
helps Russia to bypass supply lines to
Ukraine which Nye faces losing billions
in gas transit fees
it's your countries of course have been
in conflicts since 2014 let's stay with
the story Matthew browser is a senior
fellow at the Atlantic Council's Eurasia
center on global energy he joins us on
skype from Istanbul kids are happy with
us on the program Matthew and this
pipeline has been several years in the
making the tap has been turns now how
much of a game changer would you say
this is for the region well thanks for
having me holla it's it's a game changer
for Ukraine this is a largely
geopolitically intended project on
behalf of russia which would allow as we
were just saying russia to avoid sending
gas via Ukraine which number one will
really hurt the Ukrainian economy
Ukraine gets about three million dollars
a year in transit fees at number two
will maintain Russia's status as not a
monopolist but a monopolistic supplier
of natural gas to Bulgaria to Greece as
well and also North Macedonia president
hairdo one who ever said something very
significant during the conference press
conference just not with President Putin
besides strengthening turkey Russia
relations he talked about another
pipeline the tunnel pipeline from
Azerbaijan and president air21 mentioned
he called him his dear brother the
president of Azerbaijan Aloha Malia that
project is one that's been supported by
the United States as a way to give
Turkey as well as some southeastern
European countries some diversification
of gas supply away from Russia so
president Taylor ones trying to maintain
a strategic balance having both stronger
relations with Russia but also getting
some gas from Azerbaijan with
court of the EU and the United States
and and anymore turkey is also trying to
expand its influence with of course the
development of a partnership between
Turkey and Libya in terms of gas and
energy exploration it's quite a
complicated picture is it not but also
rather significant just talk us through
the various dynamics that that turkey is
is dealing with and how much were player
it has become that's a great question I
was just thinking about this and
speaking with some friends of mine
Turkey foreign policy has shifted in the
last six months or so in quite a
significant way since 1923 when the
Ottoman Empire finished and the modern
Turkish Republic was formed the the the
core motto of Turkish Foreign Policy was
peace at home peace in the world which
was sort of an isolationist approach in
the last six months Turkey has begun
asserting what it sees as its rights
throughout the Mediterranean region so
that includes Cyprus where it's begun
drilling for oil and gas in Cypriot
waters much to the consternation of the
EU that includes Syria where Turkey has
conducted operation peace Spring in
northern Syria to push the YPG give us a
terrorist militia away from the border
and then that's happening now in Libya
where Turkey has reached a maritime
demarcation agreement with Libya that
would effectively allow Turkey to claim
rights for oil and gas exploration that
otherwise Greece would claim and could
obstruct a natural gas pipeline from
Israel to Cyprus to Greece that Turkey
opposes preferring a pipeline from
possibly from Israel to Turkey
so Turkey is making three big
geopolitical moves now two of which are
directly related to energy and this is
you mentioned Cyprus there and Europe of
course there is that a that potential
agreement between Israel and Europe and
Cyprus and Greece to try and create
another pipeline there's turkey roads
with Europe does it not but it's also in
quite a tricky position because it seems
on one hand Turkey is a lying with
countries that it's there's a major
disputes with notably
Russia so are they playing their allies
off against each other what's really
going on here yeah I think Turkey that's
is trying to navigate what you described
as this incredibly complex geography
turkey is is pursuing under President
air21 if you will a turkey first policy
a transactional foreign policy much like
Donald Trump does so of course Turkey
wants to remain a member of NATO of
course turkey wants food relations with
the European Union but turkey wants to
be important in its own right that's why
it wants to become a transit hub for
natural gas
turkey is receiving gas from Azerbaijan
from Iran from Russia as we've just been
saying but also a lot of liquid natural
gas believe it or not from the United
States so Turkey wants to be the key
actor geopolitical ENGO economically in
the eastern Mediterranean anis is taking
some steps to assert those interests
okay Matthew Bryce great to get your
thoughts thank you so much for talking
to us here on al-jazeera
thanks hello